kind of a strange thing happened usually
this is weird in corporate America
usually it's a policy this gentleman's
trying to read the cue cards ahead of
time
seriously show what you're doing sir
show what you were doing show what you
were doing he was doing that so what you
were doing come on this guy this guy I
was doing the jokes and I'd see him lean
over and read what's what's your name
sir
Gus good to meet you Gus Conan how are
you this guy is leaning over reading a
little bit ahead and on one of them he
was like I need you here all the time
man if I'm doing one that doesn't look
like it's coming you can wave me off
snow take off on that one kind of a
strange thing happened well why don't
you tell Gus
[Laughter]
you're gonna read the cards read the
freaking cards right no kind of a
strange thing happened did you hear
about this yeah usually it's a policy
what's a policy so you only like to read
the cards when you're reading just a
little bit ahead of me yeah usually it's
a policy that rival companies never
mention each other right yeah yeah
that's the thing you just never do
recently subway started airing attack
ads against McDonald's true story Gus
check it out so have we started yeah
yeah it's unprecedented
well now McDonald's is fighting back
with their stop reading look at me look
at me I'm right here have it you're not
watching me on TV now you're watching me
here
peace
feel my face
is unprecedented well now subway attack
McDonald's you see McDonald's is
fighting back with their own attack ad
and it's pretty effective
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
you